in a small community in the Pacific
Northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles by being
the best and by being honest to their
customers
d is technology-driven
people focus
yeah we push a really high used
inventory turn to our dealerships one of
the ways we do it well very aggressive
marketing weekly ads statewide or
internet presence we try to push real
hard and once a year at least once a
year we have a used equipment auction
we've been running used equipment
auctions through our dealership for many
many years it's a way of freeing up some
capital and getting rid of that you
knows cleaning out the yard make room
for new stuff we generally manage the
the auctions ourselves we hire good
auctioneers we Clerk them ourselves and
cashier em ourselves and so it takes
some of the expense out I like to
control the advertising myself i doing
auctions so many years kind of know what
I think our market is and overall it
gives us an opportunity to get a real
good handle on what use equipment values
are sometimes we lose money sometimes we
make money it's all part of the deal
here
but but I'm a firm believer in the
auction process
in a small community in the Pacific
Northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles by being
the best and by being honest to their
customers D is technology driven people
focus